Even as basic a thing as flipping a device
from portrait to landscape orientation might change the best interface
pretty dramatically. Like this audio recorder I wrote, where
the best way to lay out the interface changes in
landscape mode. This isn't just reflow and percentage sizes.
I needed to change some more dramatic styling to make
this interface work well. In today's landscape, you should really
think of your designs in terms of three main scenarios.
Phone, tablet, and desktop. This may share some
design characteristics of course, and they'll certainly share data,
but you should consider the optimal experience for each
of these scenarios separately as you build your design.